so no man Skyy major update just release
a couple days ago uh yeah absolutely um
and you were playing quite a lot of it
yesterday last night
tell us about it what are the major
features that it does and overall I'd
kind of want to know if it makes a game
better than yeah ah
we'll have to like get to that later
because I have a hard time kind of
coming to that conclusion like I
definitely think it is a that intimated
is what it is like it's a cool name
because I definitely like laid some
groundwork and it made it easier for me
to actually see you know if they and I
hope they continue to like improve this
game you kind of see where they're going
but essentially yeah you it mean it
starts off and I think it caters to how
a lot of people got frustrated the game
was like it just feels like you know we
talked about world like games where it's
just getting repetitive and I'm not
seeing enough diversity in these planets
that's worthwhile so you have three
different game modes right you have your
normal one so your save is unaffected
and then you have creative I'll get to
that and then like survival so it's like
kind of like almost like as far as like
time length goes like long play short
play and like you know normal mode but
you get base building which is where the
game was lacking was I feel a direction
in some form where it was like I don't
really know what I'm supposed to be
doing at some point you know you get to
a point you kind of hit Atlas if you
chose that path and then it's like I
don't know once we'll be making there
were times on a planet where it's like
what was I doing I forget and it's hard
to pull up you know just that Waypoint
uh and so the game basically lets you
create your own base create your own
base you then bring in a specialist so
you actually the game implements more
npc aliens on Space Station so I go up I
grab a one of these guys I say work for
me my base and then he starts basically
giving me almost like side quests that
are directing me towards which is I
think the heart of the game lack thereof
is just basically technology and like a
Minecraft game you're just building and
crafting
so he's just giving me those and he's
saying you need a weapon specialist so
now I'm building basically a little
society in my own pace as well as I'm
that first guy is still also giving me
new materials to use so now I can oppose
to like the prefab circular buildings I
can now kind of go out and do whatever I
want with blocks and I can make towers
and I can do all these things so that's
pretty cool I think that's very
Minecraft and almost reminds me of like
factorio in a good way where like it
gives more Drive to be effective and be
efficient and it's more clearly laid out
it almost reminds me of Fallout 4 as
well like a lot of I didn't use the base
building in Fallout 4 as much and they
introduced in Skyrim too with a figure
with the DLC was called you could build
a house uh I feel like it's meant to
root people more in this universe
because after a while you know like with
infinite planets how do you get attached
to anyone right build a base on it right
like a home to return to did you feel
that now like you actually kind of like
going back here and stuff is this like
the the new drive for you to play this
game yeah I I think I'll play some more
of it because I haven't really come I
would say I'm afraid of coming to that
burnout phase but I see longevity
because you know I mentioned the base
building you can then get a freighter
and these actually I think are cool
right is there like the coolest part of
the game that like gives me that
spectacle back or adds spectacle to this
game where eventually you amount like
you know I think the cheapest one is
like seven mil that I saw for like a
freighter I can then land my smaller
craft on the freighter and offload
supplies and essentially the idea being
like um okay this is instead of me if
I'm doing trade routes I'm trying to
like you know get into the market place
in a different solar system I can make a
base there and and come back to that go
to a different solar system you know get
a commodity just offload tons of stuff
onto my freighter which you could also
customize to degree like your base put
storage units in there I can get there's
also like I'll get to later but yeah you
basically can just offload more and more
items onto these
freighters and then just overhaul tons
and tons of stuff and that's neat and
it's it's a cool spectacle to dislike
beyond any plan at any place and just
hit this hologram of like weird E while
your freighter to go and it just warps
in and you can like just go up to it and
just like I don't know diving down off
of it into a planet like gave me these
vibes of like aliens when they like
first do that drop or like even call a
duty like cuz that's my favorite part of
the game I think for sure is entering a
planet is just like it's dramatic it's
so dramatic and even leaving it like
hits the synth music you know like it
brings back that and I and I that was
what I first really really liked about
the game but one more side note of like
another really big one is like more
quality of life stuff so you have like a
hawk you're not looking at a menu nearly
as often we just like oh man like my um
launch pads need plutonium alright gray
I got going this menu you can do that
real quickly with this new kind of hot
menu thing which is like bam bam bam you
just throw it in and the other thing is
which is really big is say I land on a
planet I can't find [ __ ] because it's
barren
they give you basically like the ability
to throw down a device that will save
the game another one that will basically
beam out and search for those quests you
know may they be find a abundance of
resource or a colonial outpost or etc so
it's just it's just quality of life
rates like you just can find things
easier to go back to the base is quick
you might have said this so correct me
but can you just build these anywhere
you want on any planet so that's the
that's why you have this device perfect
timing earth is you set this up and then
one of the options is find me a hat
habitable base okay and then that's
where I can basically go in and it's
like do you want to set up camp here and
make this your homeworld
okay and I have that option and then
that links to any kind of Space Station
so I could go as far as I want like in
the solar system our galaxy and then
always be able to come back to that base
but once you establish that base it
stays there you can't have right in one
of those bases unless you're in a
soaring playthrough I think there's not
even made clear yet I don't know I
haven't been a
to do multiple bases but freighters you
can only have one okay just like it I
think it's very similar to your
spaceship I think you just kind of wipe
whatever you have before however
everything you had as far as items will
be transferred transferred over so
you're not really like at loss other
than like whatever time you spend into
the structure
okay so overall I mean you played an
immense cone at released P you played a
lot too you reviewed it brah that's
right Rob did you do you think this
improves it sounds like this improves
the game overall is it worth returning
to now like I guess that's like pretty
subjective question but this make you
personally want to return to it a lot
more you can be playing a lot tonight or
no personally it makes me it does make
me want to play some more of it um but I
think it's not quite there yet I'd like
to see more things like having thought
about the freighter like the freighter
so cool it's like I think it's a really
cool idea yet uh yeah you know you get
attacked by space space pirates and like
all cool maybe I can send in this
freighter which I know has guns on it
and I warp mini doesn't do anything like
it'd be cool to have that fleet or like
build up in that respect like a flee
because when you first pick the
freighter he's in like a whole group of
like other ships um it would be really
cool you know to basically have these
huge like war space battles right like
just like like bombarding other ships
like huge conflicts in space there's not
enough of that I think that could be
like what would drive me in and it would
make me want to like upgrade my ship or
a crew or ever it is I don't know I do
feel like that's the next step can do it
yeah Josh Shaw on the twitch chat was
saying shouldn't this be focused on
building ships I wonder if that is like
a step down the road I know they may be
they technically I think they hinted at
that or someone found I think some file
in the actual game of that I believe
well that would make sense I mean having
these bases that you can build on a
planet kind of routes you and won and
makes you like care about that planet
more whereas building a new ship you can
take that wherever you go and that's
like seafood you're on this game the
spectacle of discovering new star
systems new you know galaxies new
planets and whatnot feel like I'd rather
build a ship that I can take with me I
mean like obviously the freighters you
can but like in terms of the one I'm
flying I would like to put like
PETA have you do you see yourself you
liked this game you enjoyed it you think
you give a seven mm-hmm do you see
yourself returning to this at all
no just you've had it your fill of
numbers guy no I so all these things
that you're describing like they sound
great and like I sound like things that
I would love to have had access to and
the game came out totally that's how I
feel uh you know when I was first
playing my mentality was follow Atlas
because I found that path to be
fulfilling from like a narrative
perspective right like the things I was
working towards was working towards a
conclusion of my own story
both my story that I'm making now is
just to build things for myself to
marvel at that that's too that's too
shallow for me just because I don't get
a lot out of I think just base building
just for the sake of it right like even
a fallout 4 even that you had people
like NPCs that were walking around that
would change as you did that I didn't
really get what the ultimate goal was
like how was I reward it was it just the
creativity behind it it kind of seemed
to be the case and that may be true here
as well I need some greater purpose for
all of this stuff I need to feel like
what I'm doing has meaning beyond just I
can do this now and look what I made
yeah you can introduce as many features
as you want but at one point are they
still cohesive with like the overall
meaning at a game yeah and like you know
what are the challenges involved with
building right like sure there are time
and endurance based challenges where you
need to get enough resources to do the
thing but are there intellectual
challenges there in like do things
become more difficult to build or manage
or you'd literally just scaling up and
making things bigger because you have
more of the stuff that you need to do
that if that's all it is and yeah I just
I don't have any to go back I still
cherish the first you know God 6070
hours I spent with that game but beyond
that I think I I don't know that this
update will bring me in again sure yeah
yeah I would just tap on that like I
actually agree and like I'm still kind
of in that that spectacle phase of just
like this is still pretty cool looking
I'm like getting these huge freighters
space battles lighting I wish I could
see more of but yeah at the end of day I
this is how the first ya play I had with
that game ended and like even last night
till I was like 3 a.m. 4 a.m. I'm like
wait what am i doing actually right now
and that when that hit me I was like
I've seen this and so you know what it
always is though
it's when I see like the goddamn same
freaking plant when I see that plant
I've seen him I've seen him on every
planet when I see him I'm out that's it
you liar
dumb animal now how is this plan on
every planet get out of your plant you
know found that has no sleep yeah yeah
you've been playing too much no man's
guy but you're gonna play long go play
somewhere yeah well anyway so that is no
man sky news updates live now on all
platforms you can play that ps4 PC it's
all the way live yeah cool so let us
know if you plan on returning no man sky
now this update is out